[Musique]
ici le centre devait à paris eh bien
bonsoir à tous et surtout bonsoir à nos
amis du nord à nos amis de l'île
regardez regardez vous savez que depuis
hier il y à un mystère qui apparaît sur
vos écrans tous les jours à 18h20 c'est
ce schmilblick que la station régionale
de lille a choisi pour le soumettre à la
sagacité des téléspectateurs de la
france entière mais aujourd'hui et bien
ce sont les téléspectateurs de bordeaux
qui vont pouvoir tenter leur chance mais
pour les encourager je tiens à rappeler
qu'hier notre schmilblick
grâce à la sagacité des amis de la
région de strasbourg est passé de zéro à
400 francs alors ses marques et vous
l'avez sur votre écran aussi je tiens
maintenant pour donner plus de chances à
nos amis de bordeaux rappeler tous les
renseignements que nous avons
recueillies précisément en alsace et
bien un autre schmilblick qui vaut donc
400 francs ne sert pas un sportif ne
s'utilise pas dans la cuisine n'est pas
d'un usage courant pour tout le monde
n'est pas utilisée dans une maison de
chasse ne s'achète pas dans les débits
de tabac ne se trouve pas dans les
champs ne se portent pas autour du cou
n'est pas vivant n'a rien à voir avec le
courant électrique ne sert pas au
médecin n'est pas un monument n'a rien à
voir avec la menuiserie mais en revanche
peut être soulevée par une femme sert à
travailler peut très exceptionnellement
se trouvait au bord d'une route
il est conducteur d'électricité et enfin
n'oublions pas qu'il a été sélectionné
par la station de lire et que par
conséquent ils concernent un peu le nord
de la france
voilà et bien immédiatement nous nous
rendons à bordeaux nous attend notre
charmante ami dominique cendres elle
avoue bordeaux bien à vous tous bonsoir
beaucoup de monde dans notre auditorium
de bordeaux aquitaine et une forte
proportion de jeunes femmes
et comme vous venez de dire que cet
instrument bizarre peut servir ou du
moins peut être utilisée par une femme
je pense qu'elles vont trouver très vite
nous avons dans ce public
vingt-six personnes qui ont décidé de
jouer avec vous alors si vous le voulez
bien nous attendons maintenant l'ordre
de passage nous allons faire très vite
dominique son rôle très vite donner une
chance à tout le monde et tout de suite
de notre ami jean marc et pino grand
maître de cérémonie me donne les cartes
à couper de ses 26 numéros nous allons
tout de suite savoir le premier de ce
numéro et je vous rappelle qu'il y à
douze minutes de jeu
bon alors le premier candidat que nous
allons interroger sera le numéro 18 mais
attention monsieur madame ce système sur
une dame bien qu'il y ait une majorité
féminine
nous vous posons d'abord une question et
si vous répondez et si je réponds oui à
cette question alors seulement à ce
moment-là vous a le droit de donner le
nom que vous pensez à quoi vous pensez
en ce qui concerne ce fameux schmilblick
qui est déjà à 400 francs le numéro 18
est il prêt attention nous démarrons le
chronomètre pour 12 minutes tout est en
place
deuxième round du schmilblick numéro 18
mais voilà le voilà ce numéro 18 c'est
une charmante petite personne
mais elle a l'autorisation de ses
parents pour concourir et je vais lui
demander tout de suite son nom voilà
elle s'appelle jocelyne et elle a quel
âge 14 ans alors pas de profession
encore call hier lorsque christian smith
bits peut se trouver à bord d'un bateau
oui et immédiatement jocelyne grâce à
thouars grâce à vous et bien notre
public passe à 500 francs
et maintenant je voudrais savoir à quoi
pensent jocelyne c'est très important
sion périscope au périscope penser au
périscope jocelyne tu as fait remonter
schmilblick mais ce n'est pas ça vite le
numéro 12 les voilà c'est encore une
jeune personne qu'elle achemine mazel 16
ans et vous appelez genou rhuys très
bien profession lycéens et lycéennes
encore je te pose est est-ce que le
mythe blick support bardot ligue se
trouve sur le long d'un fleuve le
schmilblick palmistes b parce que c'est
pas la même chose
et bien le schmilblick se trouve
effectivement des dons alors sa part
très fort à bordeaux
aujourd'hui peut se trouver au bord d'un
fleuve immédiatement 600 francs dans la
cagnotte du schmilblick et je demande à
cette ravissante bordelaise
avance-t-elle c'est pour cette une [ __ ]
qui sert à marc et les bateaux nous
sommes dans un port vous savez guy lux
ici oui c'est vrai je pense qu'ils ont
en effet tout le monde est très très
très préféré sur la marine
et bien non ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
quelque chose pour amarrer les bateaux
et immédiatement nous passons à la
candidate ou candidat numéro 11 mais je
dois dire que bordeaux ça marche très
très fort
le schmilblick c'est ce que les vaches
et yonnel dasté voilà qu'elle a 17 ans
nuit et il fait étudiants étudiants lui
aussi alors votre question est ce que le
strip blick est quelque chose de petit
de petits c'est pas très clair peut-être
comme question qu'est ce que vous en
pensez qu'il est bien j'en pense quand
même beaucoup de bien parce que je crois
que l'or là ce sera le tiercé des bonnes
questions nous sommes obligés de dire
que je mets des békés petit par contre
je suis prêt également à dire que la
première personne qui prononcera bien
moche biblique on les donnera une prime
supplémentaire alors immédiatement 100
francs de plus dit moi ils vont nous
ruiner aujourd'hui à bordeaux et je
demande immédiate notre sympathique
concurrents à quoi pense-t-il un bouton
électrique
ah non non alors l'âme n'est pas courant
pour tout commander schmilblick et nous
passerons immédiatement au concurrent
numéro 9
voilà c'est une dame approchez vous
madame comment janot irène ajer 58
voilà et bien madame jeanneau ou pose
qu'est-ce qu'il en fallait ce que le jeu
me dire vous n'aurez pas là
alors est-ce que le oui enfin dit certes
il pour la navigation questions aux deux
ânes petit oui non ce n'est pas une
question bien que ça soit pour la
navigation ce n'est pas une question de
lag et binya temps je dois dire que le
le schmilblick qui la cagnotte des
chevilles big band de 100 enfants
regardent et 800 francs voilà déjà le
public qui est forte important poursuit
qu'il gagne à madame à quoi pensez-vous
encore une accord un accord un accord
c'est préciser votre pensée passé pour
amarrer du bateau qu'est ce que l'on
appelle ici une bitte d'amarrage
4e première candidate de la définition
tout à l'heure et bien non pas encore ça
dépasse la merci en tous les corps et
bien passive en maintenant monsieur
candidat numéro 8
coutenceau didier 26 ans une oreille
parce que le schmilblick serre dans
l'industrie du verre non absolument pas
on n'avait pas fait avancer le
schmilblick vous écartez m16 numéro 16
approchez vous vous rapprochez vous
monsieur mais on appelle la suite des
numéros inquiétez pas mettez-vous à côté
de moi votre nom votre prénom
nils abel l'agetip hostile 24 ans et
votre profil étudiant
voilà est-ce que le schmilblick peut
servir pour la couture a donné par
monsieur vous avez déjà la prime vous
avez bien prononcé le terme je sais pas
quelle est la prime
et bien non monsieur ça ne sert pas pour
la couture désolé mais merci en tous les
cas d'avoir prononcé notre schmilblick
que sans défaillance éventuellement
numéro 13 il est beaucoup plus petit et
lâche 12 est en prennant gilles bon à la
pose la question est ce que le
schmilblick peut-être n a utilisé par
marin par amarin le terme mara me gêne
un peu
et si vous le permettez nous allons
revenir sur le schmilblick l'espace
d'une seconde simplement pour le temps
de la réflexion
[Musique]
j'ai eu mon petit gilles tu fais monter
la cagnotte de 100 francs en effet le
schmilblick peut-être utilisé par un
marin à quoi penses tu eh bien je pense
un rouleau de plastique sur lequel on
enrôle les cordes à rouleaux de
plastique sur lequel on enroule les
cordes s'est consacré précis au point de
vue et bien gilles non ce n'est pas cela
merci en tous les cas d'avoir fait
augmenter le schmilblick 200 enfants qui
en est à 900 francs matin concurrent
numéro 17 et 26 ans 38 ans fonctionnant
chauffer entre est ce que ça peut être à
vie par un mort oui qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'il préparait donc question nous vous
trouverons la compagnie la question
c'est est-ce que ces neurones d'un
cerveau
voilà oui monsieur oui le marathon sur
lui-même et le schmilblick passe
maintenant à 100 à 1000 francs un petit
ennui dans la marche de notre appareil
qui n'a plus l'air de fonctionner mais
ils feront toute façon nous ne perdons
pas de temps nous réparé pour
éventuellement la caisse peut se tromper
mais nous nous trompons pas à quoi
pensez-vous monsieur j'ai pensé un gaby
oh gaby oh eh bien monsieur ce n'est pas
le nom du schmilblick
qu'est ce qu'un gagne ou le cabillaud
c'est un instrument que l'on met sur le
plat bord des navires pour prendre un
retour ça n'est pas cela monsieur bravo
à tous les cas pour être si ferrer en
termes de marges
navigation et maintenant que le public
est à 100 francs c'est à dire de 1000
francs par dont dix mille cent mille
anciens francs nous passons pour
concurrent numéro 14
on a toujours des petits ennuis oui le
numéro 14 qui était ce à voilà voilà
voilà c'est ce monsieur d'abord ce
monsieur quelle profession
je suis retraité retraités et votre nom
c'est vous pierre la vinasse pierre la
vinasse votre question vous regardez là
est ce que le méchoui sert à table
est ce que le que ça serve cimentier au
cimentier non monsieur non monsieur non
maître pierre parce que je crois que
vous appelez pierre servant cimentier
concurrents suivants l'ain par là vous
vous échapper pour laisser la place à
cette jeune personne
voilà votre nom votre prénom même à ça
qu'on est près de moi marino et
modélisation ça marche quand je me suis
un peu égaré parce que j'avais une autre
idée enfin je vous poser ma question
j'ai pas trouvé
est ce que le schmilblick certes il a un
dessin du sénateur industriel numéro 25
à monsieur plein de vitalité
c'est beau mélange très long bâtiment
est ce que le schmilblick se trouve à
l'arrière d'un bateau un moment de
silence
g
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît vous voulez vous répéter
votre question est ce que j public se
trouve à l'arrière dans ma peau non
monsieur je suis désolé ça ne trouve se
trouve pas l'arrière d'un bateau merci
en tous les cas quand et la numéro 20 le
voilà son nom françois zahoui étudiants
étudient avant 18 ans est ce que le
schmilblick sert un marin pêcheur nord
mesure absolument pas à un marin pêcheur
concurrent numéro 6 mais voilà il est
tout jeune franks à venise est ce que le
schmilblick sert à diriger un bateau
peut aider à diriger un bateau
absolument pas futur capitaine merci en
tous les cas au curragh numéro 26 est ce
que le schmilblick est un métal qui peut
être cool et attend d'abord j'aimerais
que vous précisez votre question est ce
que le schmilblick est un métal ou est
en métal est un métal qui peut être
coulé alors tels que vous formulez votre
question je suis obligé de vous dire non
non absolument pas concurrente 24 24
madame ou mademoiselle voilà une
profession
je suis professeur d'anglais très bien
posée ne posez pas la question en
anglais
est ce que le schmilblick et comestibles
merci vous étiez je crois à la dernière
concurrente nous en avons passé la
majorité il reste peut être encore
quelques concurrents oui nous est de
damas que nous avons le temps absolument
pas non vous savez que nous sommes très
pressés ou moins bien c'est bien de nous
excuser auprès de ces deux charmants et
bien je me tourne maintenant vers tous
nos amis et je tiens à préciser que le
schmilblick est arrivé ce soir à cent
mille anciens francs c'est à dire mille
francs notre appareil n'a pas fonctionné
mais je tiens à le préciser les
fonctions
fonctionnera demain rassurez vous êtes
ennuis mécaniques l'essentiel c'est que
la liaison était parfaite avec bordeaux
qu'est-ce qu'il est bien de mettre
demain à 18 heures va à nouveau nous
vous préciserons tous les renseignements
que nous avons recueillies et dieu sait
si aujourd'hui ça a été particulièrement
positif je crois que le schmilblick
l'espace jean marc a fait un très grand
pas ça se resservent sait pas s'il sera
découverte de main par nos amis de de
marseille voyez quel est le tour de
france que nous pouvons faire un autre
schmilblick regardez-le une dernière
fois et c'est sur cet objet ce
schmilblick mystérieux qui vaut
maintenant cent mille anciens francs
mille fois nouveau que nous allons nous
séparer en donnant rendez vous rendez
vous à nos amis marseillais et demain
n'oubliez pas d'être à l'écouté à 18h20
pour la suite des renseignements
puisqu'il s'agit d'un roman-feuilleton
bonsoir à tous et merci
[Musique]